(rock music)
- [Eugene] These are too sticky!
- I don't want excuses, I want results.
(coughs loudly)
It went down my mouth.
We're gonna do the Boba Ball Shoot-Out.
- [Eugene] For people who
don't know what Boba is,
it's a beautiful, delicious,
caramelly ball of Tapioca.
- The way it works is we're
each gonna take our straw.
I picked red because
it rhymes with my name.
- I picked purple because
it rhymes with nurple.
- You slurp the Boba.
- You gotta put it this way.
- Right, right.
- You're gonna stab your face.
- Yeah, I don't want to stab my tongue.
You get some Boba in your shooter.
Boom!
- So if you get a Boba to stick
on the glass it's one point,
but if it's inside the corgi
imprint it's five points.
- We got one minute to score
as many points as possible.
I really want to just eat it right now.
- [Voiceover] You guys ready?
- Yeah.
- You ready?
- I'm ready.
- I'm ready to beat your ass, bitch.
- Oh, I'ma beat your ass.
Bitch.
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one.
(beep)
(blowing noises)
- Alright, this is very difficult.
These are too sticky.
(ding)
- [Ned] Oh, that's one.
- [Eugene] This is what
aliens' babies look like.
Fuck, I keep swallowing them.
(blowing noise)
(ding)
- Fuck yeah.
- I'm totally kicking your ass.
(blowing noises)
(ding)
(laughs)
(blowing noises)
(dings)
(blowing noise)
- Aw.
- That sound is amazing.
It's like a Mario.
(game noises)
What is that?
That's pitiful.
(blowing noises)
(dings)
Ah, there you go.
- There we go, there we go.
- Ah, you know what it is.
(slurping noises)
- [Voiceover] Five, four, three, two, one.
- Yeah!
(buzzing)
- [Ned] Man, all my Boba's fell off.
- Fucking killed it.
For Asia!
- [Ned] Nah bro, I fucking got way more--
- [Eugene] I nailed it.
- [Ned] on there than you did.
- [Eugene] I still have
four up there, you got two.
- That's just because I have more saliva.
- Look at our piles, look at
our piles that we're all done.
Mine's way more.
- [Ned] I got more, I got way more.
(blowing noise)
Alright.
- Nice rebuttal.
- I guess you won.
- [Eugene] Boba fight.
(blowing noise)
- No.
(laughs loudly)
- [Eugene] Put it down,
put it down, put it down.
If this was Golden Eye, you'd be dead.
Bo-bye.
(blowing noises)
(laughs)